Xi Jinping spent the past few years
reining in China's tech giants.
Now, as he faces a backlash over his
handling of the Covid-19 pandemic, the
Chinese premier is discovering he might
need them. In mid 2020.
Alibaba and Tencent seemed on track to
become trillion dollar companies.
Then everything changed.
Concerned about their rising influence,
Xi targeted the e-commerce giant Alibaba
for perceived monopolistic conduct
and Tencent, which owns the super-app WeChat
for its tight grip on music streaming
rights.
Other tech firms came into the firing
line, too.
That appears to be changing.
Judging by an economic planning meeting
in December, during that meeting, he
signaled strong support for the tech
sector.
That's because after Covid zero
policies, the Chinese economy is really
tanking.
So right now, he needs a new way to fire
up the economy again.
That's why he's looking at tech.
Tech has been the Chinese growth
engine for the past decade.
That doesn't mean it's a return to
business as usual for China's tech
giants.
But life might start to get just a
little bit easier.